es ist der zweite juli 2009 10 zu sein
eaton ist für eine konferenz auf kreta
jan sp kommt mit dem auto vom holz
sammeln also die 59 jährige beim joggen
beobachtet nach eigenen aussagen spürte
er eine übermächtige macht der frau
zufolge näher wollte sex mit einer
fremden haben wenn es sein muss mit
gewalt
jan s p überfährt gegen mit seinem auto
zweimal erlebt die schwer verletzte
frauen seinen kofferraum für zwölf
kilometer zu einer höhle und
vergewaltigt sein opfer dort dreimal zu
diesem zeitpunkt sollten bewusstlos oder
sogar bereits tot gewesen sein
anschließend wird die an sp die
forscherin in einen sieben meter tiefen
höhlen schacht wo sie später von hobby
munition zur an gefunden wird es war
offenbar nicht das erste mal dass jan sp
versuchte eine frau in seine gewalt zu
bringen
die tarife war an himmelfahrt 2009 10
mit dem fahrrad auf kreta unterwegs als
sie mit einem auto angefahren wurde bin
ich langsam weiter gefahren in dem
offenen der sehr vorbeizieht und der
weiße wagen also das habe ich noch nicht
gesehen erst als der vorzog und meine
armbeuge sah ich dann auf einmal einen
weißen kotflügeln dachte der über
überholt und im nächsten augenblick
zieht der links river und ich verliere
das bewusstsein und sie bin dann war
wieder wach geworden paar sekunden
später ist das können nur 23 sekunden
gewesen sein und dann das fahrrad eben
da drin und ich mit der hand im zaun und
ganz an die seite gepresst und tage
später durch auch hier wieder zeit
voller prellungen
doch terry war hatte glück im unglück
sie bricht sich bei dem zwischenfall nur
die hand der so wie es aussieht denn
wenn es das gleiche war wie die von wie
das von der susanne eaton dann hatte ich
eben das glück dass der wagen sich an
der t-kreuzung sei dass er links abfuhr
von der gleichen richtungen ehepaar kam
mit einem traktor und anhänger und im
nachhinein konnten mir nicht ein zweites
mal was am tun also das wäre natürlich
ein leichtes gewesen so angeschlagen wie
ich war nur das auftauchen weiterer
passanten rettete kette rewe
wahrscheinlich
das leben zu sein ihnen hatte dieses
glück nicht
13 tage nach dem mord fasste die polizei
er hat die tat gestanden und auf kreta
begleitet den prozess für uns claudia
lord mir nun auch zugeschaltet seit
heute morgen ist der prozess gestartet
claudia wie hat sich der angeklagte
bisher gezeigt der angeklagte hat sich
absolut emotionslos gezeigt ich habe ihn
jetzt vier stunden beobachtet er saß mit
dem rücken zu den zuschauern
das war eine bitte der schwester der
verstorbenen sie wollte dem angeklagten
bei ihrer zeugenaussage nicht ins
gesicht blicken dem ist das gericht nach
gekommen
ich habe mit dem anwalt der verteidigung
gesprochen die ihm seitlich sehen
konnten
die haben mir erklärt es gab keinerlei
regungen in seinem gesicht er nahm das
alles völlig emotionslos war
und so ist auch die beschreibung des
psychiatrischen gutachtens in dem er
einen iq von 188 hat in dem gesagt wird
er liegt häufig er hat keinerlei
emotionen und keinerlei empathie kann er
zeigen
er wurde zudem mit einer schusssicheren
weste vorgeführt um racheakte aus der
bevölkerung zu verhindern dass gerade
gesagt die schwester des opfers wollte
ihre aussage nicht machen dem sie den
täter in die augen blickt wer ist denn
sonst jetzt noch bei diesem prozess
erschien von den angehörigen
es ist in der tat nur die schwester hier
vor ort sie ist mit einer
sondergenehmigung aus den usa
eingeflogen
denn die wissenschaftlerin war
amerikanerin der england englische man
der verstorbenen professorin hat es
seelisch nicht geschafft sich hier ins
gericht zu setzen und den motor seiner
frau zu sehen
er ist in psychologischer behandlung und
auch die beiden söhne die das paar hat
sind zu hause geblieben und kennen auch
nicht alle grausamen details dieser tat
ist ein absehbar waren ein urteil fallen
könnte ja es sieht sogar aus so als
würde es heute schon fallen können es
sind sehr viele zeugen gehört wurden
der anwalt des täters hat versucht noch
ein zweites psychiatrisches gutachten in
auftrag zu geben
das sieht aber nicht so aus als würde
dem stattgegeben werden so dass wir
eigentlich heute fast schon mit einem
urteil rechnen können
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren